the toronto blue jays need a home
because the
uh government is not going to let teams
go into toronto so toronto is going to
play their games outside
of uh toronto and outside of uh canada
so they have to find a place in the
united states
i guess buffalo was a possibility i'm
starting to see where maybe pittsburgh
would be a possibility as well so we
thought we would check in with the blue
jays the blue jays reporter for our
toronto affiliate tsn 1050 scott
mitchell kind enough to join us
on short notice where are my blue jays
going to be playing scott
that's the million dollar question at
this point uh i mean you kind of touched
on it the federal government on saturday
made the decision that
uh they didn't want teams crossing the
border and the concerns with
all the cross-border travel without kind
of a bubble system so at this point
they're going to go down the road with
buffalo but the problem is there they
consulted the players on saturday and
sunday
and players don't seem interested in
playing in a aaa park with a small
clubhouse and just not the
the same amenities that you're they're
used to and i'm not talking about
amenities in terms of spreads
and uh you know couches and things like
that we're talking batting cages
and uh you know underground stuff video
rooms just things like that that they're
not going to be used to that they feel
like they could uh you know have
a better uh situation in an mlb park
even if it's not their own so right now
pittsburgh is definitely
something they're looking into there are
some conflicts with dates
so maybe if that's the plan it would be
pittsburgh and then some other
combination of some other stadium for
the dates that conflict with the pirates
uh but they've put people on the ground
in buffalo too to assess
what needs to be done and the big thing
there is the problem with the lighting
they need to upgrade that
upgrade that to mlb standards and they
also need to take care of the clubhouse
and really redo it turn some sweeps into
clubhouse areas
and uh just kind of revamp the whole
kind of insides
of that stadium to make it possible for
them to work there yeah but scott you
got nine days to do that
i mean how did we get here how did we
get here where the blue jays are just
finding out
that they can't play home games well
coronavirus is how we got here and i
mean all the uncertainty just all over
the place and
the timeline's been interesting to look
at because if you talk to them if you
talk to anybody within the jays in
early june they thought they were going
to be in dunedin that's where their
spring training home is they just kind
of
revamped that you know it looks much
much more beautiful than it did and
they've put all the resources in to be
able to have their minor league complex
down there
and that's where they thought they were
going to be if it wasn't toronto it was
going to be
easy seamless transition of dunedin but
obviously the virus got in the way and
all the surge
in cases down there they don't want to
be there they don't feel like it's safe
so then they thought and put the full
court press on the federal government
and mid last week they thought they were
going to get approval and then that
didn't happen
at the final hour and now they're really
left scrambling and major league
baseball
is heavily involved as well obviously
the agreement that they came to last
month um you know has a stipulation in
there that says rob manfred can move
and relocate any team if there are
coronavirus concerns so
they're working hand in hand with major
league baseball trying to go through
this process
and the players union is also involved
because the players
on the blue jays they've indicated they
don't want to play in a minor league
park if that's possible
but you got to have i mean these guys
got to find a place to live
i mean this seems crazy are they
what are the options though you go into
pittsburgh are they going to be in
in a hotel are they quarantined in a
hotel
you know these things would take some
time to plan them out you got
nine days before they host a home game
right
that's the thing july 29th against the
washington nationals and you wonder if
maybe they can stay in washington for
that
full series and buy them some time
because they are playing the nationals a
couple days before that as well so it's
kind of a home and home
maybe you can get creative like that but
no you're right it's uh it's a it's a
completely odd and unique situation and
you know from the blue jays perspective
uh you know i you can't place any blame
on that they have the border involved
they're in a very unique position
in terms of uh 30 major league baseball
teams 29 others
you know are in their stadiums they're
comfortable so you would envision the
scenario where if they do go to
pittsburgh even if they go to buffalo
you're buying out a hotel
you're you're trying to uh you know keep
your players
as safe as possible in that sense and
keep them centrally located but
uh it's gonna cost some money and it's
gonna cost some time and resources over
this next week to figure it out because
there's no perfect plan and at this
point you know with major league
baseballs
uh planned to start flying around the
country uh you know no bubble no
quarantine
uh these players are essentially on the
honor system and it's going to be
interesting to see which teams
uh get hit by this virus which teams
don't and how this all unfolds
if i talk to you in 10 days where the
blue jays calling home
look ross atkins is going to address the
media today we may have a little bit
more clarity on that
but it sounds like they're doing
everything they can to be in a major
league park just based on the player
concerns
based on the talks with the league and
the union the league for tv reasons
would love them to be in a major league
park they'd love to have that lighting
all the amenities there in terms of that
so
you know i i would guess that we're
gonna see maybe pittsburgh uh you know
maybe a couple other
they're kind of investigating every
single stadium
in the northeast united states um at
this point i mean cleveland could be on
the table obviously there's a history
with uh the front office here in the
front office there so
it's it's uh it's a tough call at this
point but just based on the player
reaction yesterday
uh i would think buffalo is kind of uh
not the front runner at this point if
the blue jays can't figure out a major
league stadium
uh but uh buffalo probably then done
eden if uh the case load looks a little
different in two weeks there's just so
much up in the air right now it's tough
to say
scott thanks for joining us and good
luck with this process there
thank you appreciate it that's scott
mitchell he covers the blue jays for our
toronto affiliate tsn 1050.